communication completely changed as most
people think of digital telephony as a
mobile telephony and lot other things
got digitized
sheets of paper got digitized thanks to
fax machine
photographs got digitized and
engineering drawings got digitized
through scanners
and then came the digital cameras that
digitized photography
and videography and thanks to high
performance machines we could actually
have
digital production of cinema
and of course it i can go on and on
because things changed
the money became digital
and with strategic use of data the
digitization of businesses
or transforming the businesses
look at uber or ebola in this country
it changed the personal share the
transportation
the airbnb globally and the oyo globally
are fundamentally changing the personal
home stage
and look at the analysis
as i mentioned earlier ai ml is not new
the algorithms have been around
but
the problem in our time
the algorithms did not have data
we sometimes use the analogy
nature
and nurture see for a plant you need a
great seed that is nature
but you also need water sunlight maybe
some
fertilizers etcetera etcetera which is
the nurture
so the algorithms to some extent or the
nature
but the data is the nurture
and the algorithms got
significant amount of power thanks to
the data and that completely changed the
way we look at analytics look at a
simple job you are keying in
something on your mobile phone the key
strokes are captured and processed by
the local processor
but it is connected to a bigger machine
somewhere in the cloud which has access
to large number of words
so because
you have access to both the processing
power on your desktop on your hand
connectivity plus the huge power on the
cloud
together you are able to do what is
called auto fill right by the time you
type it just kind of predicts that words
fills it up
sometimes it even fills it up you know
during christmas time and all
after i typed three or four messages
happy christmas the moment i put happy i
could marry it automatically refills the
christmas today algorithms can even do
near real-time translation so all these
things are possible because of the
digitization
and because of the availability of
network
so armed with the knowledge that you
gained
thanks to the experience
and expertise
from two of the best known enterprises
one of course is peru for the university
united states
but my that happens to be my all my
writer and many of you might know but i
am just reminding that the only
university in the planet that can claim
that the first two people who set their
foot on the moon happen to be purdue
alum
right and simply learn
the amazing global online learning
platform
that has
a couple of millions
of real learners
couple of millions of real learners
these are all learners
who have kind of put in hard work
learned
rigorously
even did some examination passed it with
flying colors so they are real learners
and to talk of couple of millions of
real learners is something amazing
and though probably there are very few
organizations in the planet who can make
such claim and obviously simply learn is
the number one
and as learners as you are graduating
today you are ready to conquer the world
whichever industry segment you decide to
join
manufacturing
technology
transportation
energy
government education or health care
there are huge opportunities for you to
contribute
you can even contribute to larger issues
facing the planet particularly in the
post kobe world things like global
warming
things like safe planet
smart cities etc
so let me stop here let me once again
congratulate you on your special day
go and enjoy the rest of the function
and celebrate
and
go and make a difference to this planet
and remember purdue
remember simply learn thank you over to
the organizers
thank you professor sadagopal for your
kind words
and sharing such interesting stories
with our such interesting beautiful
lessons with our learners
it's a real pleasure and honor to have
you here thank you for taking our time
now now let's uh move on to
uh
to do some reflection on our journey uh
was it easy or was it too difficult how
was the experience with us
uh on a scale of one to five how
difficult do you guys think
this experience was let's do a poll we
have 30 seconds
all right
15 more seconds to go
four
three
two
one
all right let's see the result
we see that okay
neither too difficult d is fairly
okay so we see that the majority
lies in three and four
uh i think that's the so the number i
would say is around 3.5 which i think is
the optimum number like if the course is
too difficult then learners get anxious
like if it's too easy then there's no
fun there's no pushing
right so i think the course course is
designed in a way that so that you can
push yourself and be a better version of
yourselves i think and all of you have
proven to do that so congratulations
once again
uh
now let's move on let's listen from some
of your peers about the experience that
they had with simply learn
um
this is i think one of the most exciting
part and i would want to start
i would want to call abhishek gupta
from
pg data post graduate data analytics
program to share his experience
with simply learn
can we have avishek share his experience
please
paris can you hear me
we can hear you clearly
yeah i'm sorry i wasn't mute nobody's
can you switch on your video as well
am i
video okay my video is okay absolutely
yeah it's great okay thank you
uh firstly good morning good evening to
everyone and uh my
special regards to the distinguished
guests
uh
i feel very honored here to be attending
this convocation ceremony and virtual
ceremony doesn't rob me of any
excitement either
thank you simply learn for giving me
this wonderful opportunity to share my
experience today with all of you
how did this course impact my career my
life my learning
i'm not the one who measures the impact
by the job you get or by the promotion
you get in your career
it is very important make no mistakes
about it
but for me what this course did is to
it helped me overcome
my fear of coding
as a student of finance in my formative
years
i was pretty much allergic to coding
and the paranoia just grew on me
uh what this did course did to me was it
helped me break that artificial firewall
i had built
around myself for coding
so i think that was one of the biggest
contribution of this course to my life
because
coding for me was like a greek and latin
or an alien creature
the second impact of this course was
i always had
love for statistics
and that was one of the reason why i had
enrolled for this course
and learning this course or going
through this course
only helped me
build my my my love for this co for
statistics statistics much more
and
i think the faculty did a fantastic job
in clarifying some of the most complex
statistics concept i think uh that was
one of the biggest uh takeaway for me
that my my love for statistics only
became more intense
the other thing which the faculty did is
actually they gave us a way forward in
terms of understanding how to read and
analyze data
and for me that is one of the
fundamentals of of being in a data
analytics career
i would like to quote here margaret mead
one of the famous american
anthropologist who says that children
must not be children must be taught how
to think and not what to think
and for me
that's pretty much summed up this course
for me because they gave me the tools
that they try to taught me teach me
rather how to fish
i would not like to conclude without a
special reference to the support team
how did they respond to the constructive
feedback
they took decisive action
it's very easy when you are hearing
praises but it's very courageous to
stomach the criticism
and take it in their stride
and then act on it to improve the
situation for me
that is the real identity of any
institute and the support team running
the show
again i would like to congratulate my
fellow students the cohort team
attending this convocation today
the a big thank you for the entire
simply learn faculty team the support
staff the teaching assistant and last
but not the least the resource providers
at purdue who ensured that we had access
to one of the best learning material
thank you again it's been an honor to
share this platform with all of you and
good luck for your future endo and
please stay safe thank you
hey
thanks abhishek it's great to hear that
you enjoyed statistics and i can
resonate that if you dig deeper in in
any subject that it gets more and more
interesting so
thanks for sharing your story with us
uh let's have nancy now for from post
graduate program in artificial
intelligence and machine learning let's
have nancy share a story with us
yeah thank you so much faris for giving
me such opportunity i am
heartily welcoming to everyone over here
i must say that i won't take much time
but i'll brief i want to say as albert
einstein said
once you stop learning you start die
inspired by this quote and influenced by
my mentor i am delighted for the taking
a step forward to do my master's with a
specialization in artificial
intelligence and machine learning from
purdue university and simply
being the seasoned
tea engineer with close
a decade of work experience i must admit
that i am totally impressed by the
course curriculum timely follow-up and
communication and professionalism
exhibited by the team simply
i also congratulate to simply learn and
purdue university
staff for their successful launch of
these courses that greatly benefited iot
consultant like me
as
if i see that what is the contribution
it did in my particular lifestyle that
is what where i got a very very good
confidence
and uh talking to any senior person even
uh it's been eight years or nine years
of the experience i have gone through so
far but
lovely journey throughout the time and
it made me more confident that i was
used to before thank you so much
thanks a lot
thank you nancy uh thank you abhishek
and nancy for sharing your stories with
us i'm very inspired right now and super
energetic after listening to your
stories
um
let's let's let me uh
ask you another question how much did
these stories resonate with your own
story
on a scale of like one to five how much
do you think do you resonate with your
stories another quick poll
or do you
truly
think that these stories resonate with
you yes or no
let's see we have
13 seconds left let's see how many of
you resonate with these stories
all right let's see the results
wow
70 uh 68
of you feel that these stories are very
close to
uh your own story uh also feel free to
share your own unique stories with us
through the chat window here
will be great to see other stories as
well
all right let's get to the main agenda
all of you have made it and the time has
come
to call all
our achievers i would like to
congratulate each one of you for this
massive achievement let's start with
post graduate program in artificial
intelligence and machine learning
congratulations
we have more in artificial intelligence
program
congratulations jyoti
nancy akshata madhuri kamakshi swati
yogesh
prabhat
rajesh
ketan
okay now we move to the data science
postgraduate program well done mukesh
velav
rajiv
sukhanya supriya varsha
raj chandra
lovely sunil priyanka dhanya bharat
sanika varmathi adrenis dm meri
[Music]
folks
now we have our postgraduate program in
data analytics uh
weldon lisa mumta marie
pinaka veena
abhishek
data analytics
swastika puja
kesley
[Music]
is
xavier
yana teresa gaurav abhishek
okay now we move to our post-graduate
program in data engineering
congratulations kelly deepak
well done folks
now we move to our business analysis
postgraduate program congratulations
nithya swapnil christina
ashwini christopher divya sharin peace
annapurnia
roshiro srishmita
ranjita
next
we have more in business analysis
folks okay now we have lamb
christopher
marcilla maria
roger
alfonso danish
adiola judith
tesleem
is
[Music]
ishwarya christopher
sandra srividya vishal kumar
chitra
hebi siddhi rahul raina riya
kalyani
ibrahim
okay let's move to our digital marketing
postgraduate program uh congratulations
rahul
all right ah now we come to the next
section which is
superstars among achievers we have some
folks who have done exceptionally well
in assessments and some folks who have
completed the program really fast so
there are two awards that that we are
going to
reward today so one is
scholars award and the second one is
speedrunner award scholars award is
granted to
those learners who've done exceptionally
well in assessments so let's start with
our scholars award
okay let's start with our data science
scholars now very very well done vipin
abhishek hameed james
now we have our artificial intelligence
and machine learner scholars
awesome work
radhakrishnan yogesh satyajit
now we have our business analysis
postgraduate program scholars
our congratulations
huge
round of applause to hamad james
maheshwari
and now we have our data engineering
scholars
congratulations deepak and gadesh raj
really good work
uh weldin rhian
uh
gabriel hari weldon data analytics
scholars
now finally we have our digital
marketing scholars uh very very well
done parvati
daryl
elizabeth
uh now before we move on to the next
section
uh it will be great to hear from
some of the scholars who've performed
like really well so i would like to
i would like to invite abhishek khan who
is the scholars award winner for data
science category
i wish it would be great if you could
share your experience with us
yeah
are you able to hear me well and
video is clear right your video is
absolutely good yes okay
so first of all like i i'm grateful to
simply learn as well as purdue for
providing us with wonderful course on
data science
throughout my course what i feel is that
all the faculties were great and i
provided the best effort in
understanding our queries and answering
them they had like made the complex uh
concepts very clear
and simplified them so that it was easy
to understand and with examples like
they have given us a lot of examples and
with practical examples that has allowed
us to like uh
to drill deep into the data science
program and
like i am practically working on the
data governance side so basically we are
the uh
like people who solves the problem for
the data scientist so right after this
course i know what is the other side
looks like like from the data science
perspective and now with both
combination i can work on it full scale
like end-to-end implementations of a
data science in a company with quality
data so after this course i have
knowledge of both data science and
governance which allow me to develop
processes across organizations so that
we can get accurate data and
like which will be available for best
analytics
now
i in my company i have started involved
in the data science project and slowly
contributing towards it and i can now
relate various concepts that we have
been taught in the class and i am sure
that it will help me in my career path
and lastly i like to thank my fellow
graduates for helping me out with some
queries during the session as well as
congratulate them for their graduation
program and all the faculties that has
helped exceptionally well and taught us
a wonderful concept thank you very much
thank you senpai thank you party
university
thank you abhishek thank you for sharing
your story with us
now let's have romel
as scholar award winner for our post
graduate program in business analytics
let's have romel share his story
can we uh can we unmute romelu
okay all right romel can you hear us
okay uh
okay maybe we can uh get back to roman
later let's have parvati our scholar
award winner for uh post graduate
program in digital marketing let's have
parvati share our experience
good day to family
friends faculty and fellow graduates
i would like to thank the respective
guests for honoring us with their
presence
i'm really privileged to have been
chosen to speak here today
firstly congratulations to all my
batchmates of the postgraduate program
and digital marketing
the past six months
had definitely been a beautiful journey
and one that changed my perspective of a
lot of things in life
i was confused and worried about what
next in my career
i'm glad to have this newfound
confidence i gained through this course
the detailed curriculum
assessments and projects gave me a good
idea of the basics as well as digital
marketing trends
i'm happy that we had an amazing faculty
faculty from simply learn and the purdue
university to guide us through and help
us get hands-on experience enough to
make us industry ready
this course would help kickstart the
career for a fresher like me
today we have the good feeling factor
that comes from knowing that we have
done our best we have achieved and
qualified
we didn't do it alone of course
all along the way
we had the wonderful support of our
families
finally i would like to wish my fellow
graduates health and happiness in the
future and the satisfaction of knowing
that whatever they do they'll do it well
thank you
thanks pavari thank you for taking our
time to share your stories
all right let's now move to
the speed runners award the second
category of awards which is given to
folks who have finished or completed the
program the fastest
let's move on to these awards
okay let's start with that artificial
intelligence and machine learning
program congratulations
very well done satyajit congratulations
she'll be well done siva
now we have data analytics speedrunners
very very well done param sheet delhi
data engineering
very very well then rishabh prithi heber
excellent work now we move to data
science speed runners uh congratulations
hamid andrea kalpana very very well done
business analysis we have deepti
christopher
ziankai
now finally we have in digital marketing
we have
marco and uganda
excellent
work uh
guys
now in speedrunner also i would uh like
siva to
to say a few words uh civi is our
speedrunner award winner
from artificial intelligence and machine
learning
program
us
can we unmute seva
can you see me can you hear me
we can hear you
now we can see you as well yeah thank
you
so it's it's uh such a wonderful feeling
to be here today
and uh if somebody had told me that
after working for 25 years i'll go back
to class and learn something
just a year ago i would have laughed at
them
it's surreal
where i have come what i have done for
the last one year
uh it was an insane amount of work
i am
a co-founder and a startup
so managing the work at office and
managing the course load
was
sometimes i felt terrified
almost i was thinking what did i do and
there were many many doubts right
through the journey
so
it was exciting exhilarating like you
said at the beginning paris and also
abhishek talked about it at the
beginning
without challenges
life is no fun
so
those challenges kept me alive they kept
me alert
i had a wonderful group of
batch mates i think one of them is on
this
ceremony today the others aren't but uh
amazing bunch of people i met such a
wonderful group of people who were
motivated driven
um and
for somebody who was
quite convinced that he will flunk the
course to be here talking about it in
convocation as
somebody who's won an award is i'm still
pinching myself and thinking this can't
be real
it's amazing
i have nothing but gratitude for purdue
and the wonderful instructors that i've
had the privilege of learning from
um
the amount of knowledge that i have
gained uh
you know i've already started sharing
you know people and i'm sure professor
gupta and professor ali gamal
will understand knowledge gained and
shared doubles triples quadruples in no
time
uh so i'm using every bit of the
knowledge that i have gained in the last
one year i'm sharing it with my
colleagues we are trying to build
something
exciting and new
in the field of artificial intelligence
and
what i have now
is an additional set of tools and
i'm sure
i'll find some very interesting use
cases for it
but thank you once again and it's been
an amazing journey and i look forward to
the future with a lot of
curiosity i think that's what defines us
as learners
so there is more learning in the future
that i'm certain uh which direction i
will go is something that i'm waiting to
discover thank you so much
that's a great story
i think we're really inspired by it yeah
thank you absolutely
uh paris can we go back to james romel
because i think he was finally able to
switch his video yeah let's let's do
that is
is my audio uh i'm audible you're
audible yes james yeah okay
so just say give me a few seconds please
okay
so
well it's uh
yeah now you can see me i believe
yeah
yeah so
it's a
a really wonderful program so at the
very beginning i'd like to thank you all
of the distinguished panelists and
specifically your experience and towards
your experience to our experience and
how we move on still there is a
guideline well i
must
say
i mean thank you all the distinguished
panelists teacher but especially
professor sharda gopan and
his experience and good guidance that
how will move well
very shortly how it's really
help this program i'm in this industry
uh for a long time indeed the project
manager but uh well coming across
different problems significantly with
different solution well this program in
business analytics and the business
analysis has helped me uh it's designed
in such a way that this gave me a
methodological way to move on well
technology is changing every moment so
and we are moving to so it's a good
guideline now i'll come back to the
very two good points that i like to
highlight about the faculty well
uh
their real-time
experience and solution which really
helped me
other than
the you know the
books and all these materials
well
um ccba has his own curriculum on
big 500 pages books with this diagram
and everything but the solution with
difficulty is really helping me a lot
and thank you all the faculties
especially at this time and
uh two more thing well
about the simple learn family well i
must pay my gratitude all of the family
members especially the course
representatives
uh the gta customer service these people
are i mean these family members i'm i
must know the people but these are the
my family members they're wonderful they
kept me on track as a working people
sometimes i get track of that okay when
the course is there one is not but they
are really guiding me as a family member
so thank you everyone in one shot thank
you all the uh students candidates
graduates uh congratulations all of you
and once again i must say to all the
panelists distinguished final panelists
for your wonderful presentation which
really help us
i mean help us all
so thank you and have a very wonderful
day
may god bless us all thank you and thank
you
thank you james i'm truly energized
listening to you all uh very
energizing uh part of my day i would say
now let's have uh rishabh
uh our scholar award winner from data
engineering team
share story
can we unmute rishab to be
i think rishabh had to drop out
rapper for some uh
network issues maybe we'll come back to
in paris sure sure let's go
let's move on yes
so now i would
like to introduce you all to the team
behind the scenes
working relentlessly to make sure you
have the best learning experience
and the idea behind this is to put a
face to the names you've heard and
interacted with in the past one year uh
first i would like to introduce our
faculty team
uh we would like to take this
opportunity to think uh to thank uh our
faculty for constantly supporting us
throughout the program they have been
the major pillars of
your experience uh thank you uh faculty
team
uh i would now like to call a few of our
faculty members to speak about their
journey with us
let's have bernadette
share a journey
me okay
we can hear you bernadette uh yes
hey
absolutely so um
it is a very exciting time for everyone
who is on the call congratulations to
each and every one of you
and just very quickly i started this
journey as an instructor with you all
about four years ago
and just like many of you starting the
program i know that you were not sure of
what to expect
and after many late nights and early
mornings with you
there were specific characteristics that
each and every student that i've
encountered would simply learn as well
as with the purdue uh university program
cohort that i have noticed
the first one was drive
and every single student had a very
unique drive to learn the information
and for some of you it was
going on two o'clock in the morning
and you were still excited and engaged
in every class and i want to say to you
all
that each and every one of you that
exhibited that particular
characteristics these are the things
that are going to help you go far
after graduation
every note that you took
everything that you typed in the chat
every project that you completed
all of these things took great tenacity
it took great skill
and it took great strength
and everyone from the instructors
to the program creators to the
developers
are all very proud
of all of your contributions
so in terms of my journey here each and
every time i start a new class i think
about all of the students that came
before you all
that had that same drive and where
they're going
there was a quote that i had in my last
class
and a student really touched me because
she reposted it on linkedin
she said i learned something new
i learned that i don't have to be the
first to do it
i just have to be the best at doing it
and so to each and every one of you
even though you won't be the first
data engineers you won't be the first
digital marketers you definitely possess
the skills the qualities
the education the qualifications to be
the very best at what you do thank you
guys so much
thank you bernadette
now let's have maria share her
experience
hello everyone first of all a very good
morning good afternoon and good evening
to each of you
i know all of us are from different
regions
so um first of all congratulations okay
so this is a big journey like i've
achieved uh it's not easy it was tough
it was a mixture of
effort
hard work dedication and
z at the same time so i would say
everything put together is exactly what
you're experiencing today as a
convocation and for me it is interesting
this is my first virtual convocation
i've been through a physical one and
this is the first one i'm being part of
so if you look at it in a you know in a
way of experience my story that i want
to share today is
how we need to be as a faculty we need
to have a lot of patience
to deal with the questions and answers
and trying to make them understand
especially in a virtual world
at the same time this is also
the same thing with the associates who
are part of us because they should have
the patience to ask the questions and
you know try converting that into
the expected answers and in the end of
the day come up with solutions which
they feel is relatable
so with my journey i am happy to say
that most of the associates have put
that effort and that's exactly why
they're here
before i end it for the day i just want
to mention one thing
uh anything that you learn out of
anywhere in your life it is of course
going to help us
in making decisions in moving forward
and especially growing
but learning as an experience as a
subjective experience only shows us how
much more we can do for tomorrow and how
much we should not limit ourselves with
so
that is exactly what i want to say and
before we end it i want to say thank you
so much for giving this opportunity to
do and simply learn
so that i could have my words um you
know out here so all the best in your
future careers
and congratulations again
uh
well thank you bernadette and thank you
maria for sharing such rich insights
with our learners today uh
let's move on to the next uh
slide uh
we would also like to
thank our master class instructors
they they've facilitated us with
very interesting topics uh every month
uh
so these are our data science artificial
intelligence and data engineering master
class instructors
that's who
our digital business master class
instructors very rich interesting topics
every month
let's let's move on
now let's move on to the core
team at simply learn so this is our
learner success team so he this is the
team
who is responsible for the sessions and
the tickets
that you post
and many would have
many of you would have interacted with
them directly or
like indirectly
so this is our learner success team for
data science artificial intelligence and
data engineering
courses
let's move on to
yeah so
these are our learner success managers
for digital business programs
this is our leadership team
this is our faculty team uh they are
responsible for handpicking and getting
some of the best trainers
let's move on
our product team this is the brains
behind the
uh
behind the program and structuring it
they have been the bridge between simply
learn and
purdue
let's move to the content team uh this
is the team responsible for all the
interesting content and curriculum that
that we've been through in our live
virtual classes
and our and our self learning videos
let's just take a moment
to thank and
applaud them for all their efforts uh
thank you team uh thank you so much
uh
now i think right now all of us are in a
super happy mood uh and
happiness is only real when it is shared
so i would
say that let's just share this happiness
with the world right now
through all the different channels
facebook linkedin
instagram
twitter
well uh
we wish each and every graduate all the
very best for the future
and
and we believe that
being aspirational is just the first
part of being successful
many of you will excel in different
streams of your career
once again it's a heartfelt gratitude
from us
for you
choosing simply learn to be
your partner to scale up thank you once
again everyone for making time for this
event
we want to leave you with one thought
today
you are now our ambassadors for the
purdue simply learn pg program
people will now follow your footsteps
and you will be the guiding light to
success
we would request you to be active
in our communities
and post some interesting topics
for future learners future leaders and
keep us posted
about your success stories tag us
so that we can celebrate
as well as set the path right for the
future
leaders and future learners as well
thank you once again for making this
event a successful one
one last time it would be great if you
could share your views about today's
event in the survey link posted in chat
box good night
yeah sorry abhishek any final thoughts
from professor other open and professor
ali
as we wrap up
hi from my side this is
okay so from my side
i think i enjoyed every minute of the
program
and you know as a purdue alum so i kind
of switched back to some 46 years back
so thank you for making me 46 years
younger today at least for these two
hours
and thank you simply learn tea
and nice to see another colleague
professor ali gomez from purdue and you
know i just transported to west
lafayette campus you know 8 000 miles
away without getting out of my seat what
a great stuff and i particularly felt so
good that
400 plus of the learners are kind of
walking out of the portals of purdue and
simply learn
and uh
hope somewhere sometime we will kind of
our paths will cross and i think what
can be more satisfying that we are
creating a better planet by having
better people with better training i
think i'll stop there thank you
thank you sir
yes professor
thanks professor
and it's great to see you
and uh
thanks a lot for having me good luck
everyone in your journeys with what
you've learned
thank you thanks a lot professor
thank you
thank you sir
thank you
thank you all uh
good night uh good night
and wish you a lot of success
bye-bye thank you
thank you
thank you abhishek
thank you thank you the whole team
okay so coil
and uh sohini
perez of course you perhaps you did a
great job i think you know
your energy levels were as the same at 8
7 45 pm and now 9 10 p.m it's quite hard
to match you made it thank you thank you
sir thank you sir thank you everyone
thank you
you